- A fascinating legal
issue has come up again
in the Derek Chauvin trial,
specifically with respect
to third degree murder.
Now, we've talked about this
in the past, on this channel.
Third degree murder is not as severe
as second or first degree murder,
where you're doing
something that is clearly
going to injure other people.
So it wasn't a surprise that
prosecutors charged Chauvin
with that particular crime.
But there was language
in the Minnesota statute
that made it seem like,
you had to direct that sort of conduct
towards multiple people.
You couldn't direct that kind of conduct
towards one particular person.
Well, the Minnesota Court of
Appeals stepped in and said,
no, that's not the case,
you can actually direct it
towards one particular person
and still be guilty of
third degree murder.
Andrew from opening arguments was right.
He was leading the charge and said,
the interpretation of this law that said
you couldn't direct it towards one person
didn't make any sense.
The Minnesota Supreme
Court could still step in
and reverse the Court of Appeals,
but it does appear that
Chauvin was correctly charged
with third degree murder
and the jury will go forward deliberating
on that particular charge.
Go listen to one of my
favorite legal podcasts,
"Opening Arguments", or
I will see you in court.